the review of tmnt shredders revenge has  got a lot of us  pretty excited so let's keep the  nostalgia train rolling and take a look  back on the evolution of the teenage  mutant ninja turtles  in games before you grab yourself a  slice of pizza and get comfy consider  giving this video  a thumbs up alright let's go  [Music]  no  [Music]  charged  [Music]  that's that yes  molina stuff  [Music]  you make bebop look good you will suffer  my turn  [Music]  what  [Music]  there we have it nothing quite hits like  a good fix of nostalgia  what was the teenage mutant ninja  turtles game you grew up playing  let us know in the comments and if you'd  like consider giving us a sub  as well alright thanks for watching  till next time see ya  you